when you're working with leonardo
dicaprio you do the movie romeo and
juliet with him you go later on and you
audition for the movie titanic which was
a blockbuster you get the part they want
you for the lead in titanic you turn it
down because you said it would be
redundant to be in a movie with leonardo
dicaprio and play his love interest yeah
i i i mean
i don't know if i like got that i think
okay don't be modest um you got the part
kate winslet ended up taking it right
yeah it was going to shoot in mexico
city where we had just filmed romeo and
juliet for another six months i was uh i
really needed another
experience
take me into this yeah when titanic and
i'm thinking back that movie won all
kinds of academy awards it was one of
the biggest blockbusters of all time
from a career standpoint
are you then saying oh my god what did i
do this would have been huge this would
have put me on the map
you know really solidified me i didn't i
mean i remember when leo was deciding to
take that movie he really wrestled with
it it's a it was a profound choice and
really the question was
do i want to go off into the
stratosphere right now
and i think
he decided that he did and i think i
decided that i didn't
when you read the script you knew that
it would be a game changer yeah so you
made the decision i think i really
wasn't ready to i had a lot more
developing to do as a person i knew i
wanted to go to college that is an
amazing thing to say no to stuff like
that that's something i've struggled
with my whole career it's very hard for
me to say no there are things that are
offered to me that i know would be big
in my career and i feel like i have to
grab them
i would think a young actress would just
say oh my the fame thing and and the
quote goes up in the money and
everything that comes along with titanic
if you're not deeply aligned with that
choice it's not it's not going to serve
you it's not going to benefit you that
is very evolved
it's just true
you